le mythe d'hitler qui est vendu aux
allemands c'est le führer qui sait tout
qui travaillent jour et nuit dont la
lumière dans le bureau ne s'éteint
jamais c'est l'exact contraire de la
réalité il est un dilettante ne
travaillez jamais vraiment c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais travaillé si
quelqu'un qui ne supporte pas l'effort
intellectuel à long terme et de longue
haleine et qui est incapable de lire un
dossier de plus de 20 par elite l'air ne
travaille en fait hitler m se retirer
dans son refuge comme un artiste qui
plane au dessus de la réalité
une poignée de collaborateurs
travaillent à sa place
il s'appelle joseph goebbels
heinrich himmler ou albert frère
hitler a mis plus de quinze ans à les
recruter
dire aujourd'hui que c'est un bon
gestionnaire de ressources humaines il
sait très bien entouré en choisissant
comme compagnon des gens qui lui
apporter à chaque fois quelque chose de
supplémentaire